hi everyone this is jeremy schieffen at
khan academy thanks so much for joining
us this afternoon or this evening we're
thrilled to have you online with aaron
hill an awesome social studies educator
ap
expert and general khan academy guru
um as you probably know at this point
aaron is one of our khan academy
ambassadors which means she's used khan
academy even before this crisis started
for years and years so she knows the
product inside and out and she can give
you particular expertise about how con
is used in the social studies setting
as you probably also recall if we've
joined other webinars we want to make
these sessions as interactive as
possible so if you've got questions for
aaron about anything that pertains to
the site or even beyond you can ask
those via the questions feature right in
the go to webinar control panel
so that being said before we get to the
questions i'd love to get to know you
better aaron so tell us a little bit
about your own educational journey and
what's brought you to this moment yeah
um my educational journey started with
um
a background in history my degree is uh
in history and i have a credential
in social science and um i was fortunate
to start uh
teaching 24 years ago
um specifically in middle school where i
uh taught both english and history so i
was able to uh find the constant
crossovers
between the two subjects and i came to
long beach 20 years ago i was very happy
to come down to long beach and teach
both english and social studies and
again very fortunate
to be t to where i taught both ap
english language and ap us history uh so
i saw um ap from different uh sides but
i also taught uh general history
general english and also honors history
so a little bit of background on that
and then um
currently i am the ap coordinator uh at
millikin high school in long beach
very cool and such a perfect background
because i know there are lots of
questions not just about social studies
but about ap and i believe you also have
some sat experience for folks who are
curious about what's happening with that
right now in this moment so yes again
totally um lots of great expertise on
display here folks if you want to talk
social studies ap sat you've come to the
right place
and fortunately fortunately one of the
great things um that i was a the way i
was introduced to khan academy was
through uh sat
and um because we were um told by our
district uh superintendent chris
steinhauser um we have this new vehicle
that we want teachers to start trying
out in their classroom it's khan academy
they have this wonderful um relationship
with college board to help prep for the
s.a.t and a bunch of a small group just
started running with it and expanded
from there and saw all the the wonderful
potential for students in and out of the
classroom
that's awesome and so in addition to
sort of using khan academy's free essay
tool preparation tool uh tool
what other sort of khan academy pieces
of content or courses do you either use
or recommend that teachers in your
school use
um well
the teachers at our school at um at
milliken and throughout long beach um
have utilized khan academy for various
levels of math
um for english for uh the different
subjects within science uh we even have
some of our pe teachers
using some of the health
links within khan academy we have
our computer courses utilizing khan
academy
specifically for some of the coding and
ap communication science principles um
we have some of our uh business uh
teachers um utilizing um some of the uh
finance and uh marketing uh connections
with khan academy so across the board is
really how millikin and also long beach
by extension is using khan academy in
the classroom
very cool i can tell that long beach
unified is definitely a con power user
district so it very much is and
it was
not just
because it came from the top down
where it was introduced to us by again
superintendent steinhauser
but once the teachers started
trying khan academy and seeing what was
available to them they started thinking
about the possibilities of how it could
enhance
um not just their lessons but also
make um some deeper connections for the
content with their students
very cool
and so now let's sort of fast forward a
little bit to the current moment that we
find ourselves in
and imagine you're an ap us history
teacher a world history teacher
you're doing great getting ready for the
big exam in the springtime and then all
of a sudden this happens
yeah if you were totally brand new to
khan academy and just coming to this
webinar for the first time
what kind of like initial steps would
you recommend that a teacher in those
shoes takes to really get started with
this platform or potentially use it to
serve their students
the first thing that um i would
recommend any teacher starting with is
exploring what's available on khan
academy
just because
they might be teaching
ap us history doesn't mean that
the
questions or the content or the
documents within the us history content
wouldn't be uh beneficial to them or um
different aspects under government
because again there's a lot of crossover
with regard to the content um exploring
what's available what are they already
doing and um see what can supplement
um their what they what they're already
doing in the classroom because one of
the great things about khan academy in
particular is it's not replacing the
teacher it's not replacing the content
it is
again as i said earlier enhancing what's
already happening it's allowing students
to look at something from a different
perspective and already build upon uh
their prior knowledge or connections
they have with a particular subject
whether it is colonialism or the great
depression or the gilded age there's
different aspects within it whether it's
a video whether it is a document whether
it is multiple choice questions so
they're looking at the content
from different lenses
and they're able to see what
parts they understand
and get that reinforcement of oh i know
exactly what this is saying or
look at maybe um the idea of social
harmonism in the gilded age which is
one of which was a very important area
within u.s history and what are those
connections not just within that time
period but also making connections as
the content moves forward um into the
different decades
very cool and so you've talked about
this sort of holy trinity so to speak of
the videos the articles the exercises
if a teacher is starting to explore them
and say hey this is pretty good content
this is pretty well aligned with our
standards
how would you go about sort of
incorporating that into your existing
practice or even your new practice of
doing remote teaching
it depends on what the lesson is going
to entail um
if i am going to be looking having my
students analyze uh different
perspectives i might look at the
different documents that are available
within a unit and i can i can do a
modified maybe gallery walk or a
modified jigsaw where i can split my
students into smaller groups or even
assign individuals certain documents and
as we go into a group discussion whether
it is through
a webcast or an audiocast have the
students discuss what they have but also
have the students upload the document
to maybe the classroom or to
the classroom locker so the other
students can see the annotation and the
document at the same time and it becomes
a larger learning experience where the
student isn't just learning from me
they're also learning from the other
students at the same time
i love that so really sort of empowering
the students to sort of direct their own
learning get their hands dirty with
history absolutely absolutely
yes oh one of the one of the things
about khan academy that i've appreciated
the most over the years is the fact that
it does
lend itself so easily to student
engagement and interaction and it allows
them to see where they are in the moment
but also what they can do
to move forward and to continue to build
their knowledge and understanding of a
concept
great so we can definitely go into more
depth as far as sort of executing how do
you make an assignment or how do you
give out an exercise if folks want they
can definitely let us know through the
questions feature but let's actually
move towards the ap context so
as all the ap teachers out there know
ap moving to this new online testing
format for the spring yes
recommendations about how they can think
about preparing for that whether it
involves using khan academy or not um i
think that because
a lot of the students and teachers might
be uncertain of exactly what
um is going to be happening moving
forward even though the college board
has said here's what we're going to be
focusing on for um
different areas for example in ap us
history and
ap world and ap euro um they will be
giving a documentary document based
question well khan academy has
a lot of documents that are embedded
into each of those subject areas again
whether it's documents themselves or
multiple choice or even aspects of the
video so a teacher can look at the
different units that the college board
will be covering because it's a short
time frame um with which they're basing
a document-based question
they can really hone in on what their
students maybe need a little bit more
review on and then find those documents
that best fit
um a particular era or um if i'm looking
at world history i might want to look at
documents um specifically for
civilizations
um that do a comparison of civilizations
or changes over time which are common
themes within uh history
wonderful
and then finally for the sort of sat
question before we move to questions
from the audience
um i know that may be the most difficult
to solve given that basically it looks
like a very sort of bleak future in the
short term as far as testing dates go
any advice that you're giving to
teachers or to students who are trying
to figure out hey how do i get my
students prepared for whatever the
future entails
um i every time that i talk to a student
about the sat it's really connecting
them
um linking their college board in their
khan academy account but not just saying
we're linking them together actually
going into
their college board account to look at
their last score report whether it was
from a prior psat or the first time they
took the sat
and they can actually look at question
by question um from the psat
unfortunately they don't do that for the
sat because it's a more secure document
but for the psat they can look at um the
actual questions but one of the things
that i
purposely do
is you can look at the category of each
question
whether it is words in context or um
the social uh the social studies or the
science whatever it happens to be then
the student themselves empowering them
as khan academy often does
empowering the student to look at what
are their own areas of need
because even though khan academy gives
them
um
a look at where their current skill
levels are having the students look at
their sat score report question by
question looking for patterns what are
their top three areas of need then they
go to their khan academy s.a.t areas
whether it's the reading and writing or
the math and now they have what are
their three areas of need instead of
more past i mean you know the
recommended questions are wonderful and
i love those but giving the students the
chance to really choose
looking at what their scores are and
knowing in inside themselves what they
really need to focus on
then they can go through the sat
practice and become really down into the
detail of where their areas of you are
cool i love that theme of sort of giving
students agency during this tough time
because if ever there is a moment when
we need them to get involved in their
own learning
absolutely and one of the things is even
though students will get our printed
score report
it doesn't give as much detail as the
online score report and that's really
where
the power comes in of not just the
college board link but also the khan
academy connection
cool well i think this is a perfect
moment to switch over some questions
from the audience uh renee is saying
hello from james berg hello renee thanks
for joining us
um let's start with a great question
from joe and this is like a really a
really juicy question right now okay
which is how would you recommend
incorporating project-based learning
with what we're talking about here with
khan academy is there some kind of
connection you can make especially given
the sort of difficult circumstances we
find ourselves in
i would and this was a great piece of
advice from um one of the curriculum
leaders in uh long beach uh natterfold
who's also uh very familiar with khan
academy and has worked with it often um
looking at
projects and this new online learning
as a field trip
what is this new exploration
um that the students are gonna get from
this um because you want to
give the students that sense of
connectedness
but also give them that sense of what is
it that we're going to explore what is
that
question that we're going to be
discovering what is that essential
question what is that
mystery that we're going to be solving
and if you're looking at a project
depending kind of on what it is
um you can have this you can almost use
it as
within a unit and khan academy and i'm
thinking social studies in particular
um you can have the students
um
use the documents use the questions use
the video
to create their own um lesson and
sometimes and it could be
um like a one pager where they have
created
um
what is an overview and in my mind right
now the gilded age what is an aspect of
the gilded age or what is um give me a
one pager about the muckrakers during um
the progressive era and what are some of
the images that would best work what are
some of those quotes what are some of
those dates and details if i were to
um
use this as a study guide for other
students what would that look like and
then um the t what the as a teacher can
do is they can create a locker within
their classrooms
of the different student work and now it
becomes a resource not just for them but
for the other students so i was thinking
more project-based of individual
students
to help other students prepare for an
exam or to enrich their learning or
because technology is so advanced um
using maybe a google doc or um google
form google sheet whatever that happens
to be and you can have um collaboration
um within a project whether that's
slides or
some other vehicle to uh get the ideas
across so project-based learning i don't
think should be shied away from
um i think that
it can't like anything it can't just be
thrown at the student good luck we'll
see you in a month um there have to be
it would have to be broken into smaller
pieces and in some cases maybe allowing
the students to decide what that final
product may look like
but here are their parameters that the
teacher has set for them and what
aspects of khan academy um they would
want to incorporate into it
so cool yeah i was just imagining like
an amazing project around you know pick
a era of american history it's parallel
to today whether it's the golden age or
the spanish flu of 1918
and pull together the similarities and
the dissimilarities yeah absolutely the
continuities and changes over time which
is
absolutely key in social studies yeah
love it okay so let's take a step
backwards actually catherine wanted to
take you up on that offer of saying okay
i am literally just getting started with
khan academy how do i even set up my
class can i link it to google classroom
what are those steps
yeah um so one of the things that khan
academy has done for
teachers is
there's actually a section uh when you
create your khan academy account is you
click on resources and it will give you
it's how do teachers get started from
some from simply as how do you create an
account to how do you set up your class
um what are the courses within that
class that you want to create
um do you want to connect it to the
google classroom do you want to
um what are the parameter what are the
parameters for setting an assignment
what is the what are the class or
classes that you want to uh give an
assignment to
so
the way the teacher can get started is
honestly watching
the short videos on how to get started
if you are um
not quite as ready to just go click what
i call click happy and just see how
things go um
and one of the things that khan academy
also does uh with many other videos is
they also give um text instructions
so it's helping teacher a teacher
however
they are comfortable with setting
something up to set the classroom that's
going to best meet their needs so for
example um some of the teachers will
have multiple courses
underneath one course so as i said
before ap us history might also add
uh u.s government ap government and also
uh us history
as aspects of their class
just because they might want to do
smaller uh different assignments other
than different courses
so i appreciate the fact that when
you're adding a class and adding courses
that khan academy gives you the list of
different courses available
and it's not limited to
one area in particular that it does
allow for
whatever
support your students may need within
that particular course or if they need
foundational support um it's also there
for them too and uh thank you for
showing that on your screen um invite
inviting to the google classroom which
is so
effective not just prior prior to our
current situation but even more so today
because
um that is one of the ways that
so many students are able to more easily
get their information and it also houses
things in one place so you're not having
the students go to five different sites
to find um their one assignment and uh
once um a teacher set up their classroom
um and they can give an assignment they
can
you know set the parameters of when that
is
and i like the fact that khan academy
has um
set up the student home page
uh to be extremely user-friendly and
intuitive
so the students don't have to constantly
search for
what assignment is due
so um and thank you for bringing up a
student page
so we're looking at that so what are the
current assignments that the students
need to
be thinking about but also if they're
students who may have missed a deadline
they can click on pass and go to the
past assignments and i like the fact
that it has the status
of that assignment in there
and so um
for multiple choice or quizzes um things
like that
um it does give the percentage and some
teachers do allow their students to
um redo or retake quizzes um to reach a
certain percentage uh which is nice and
then on the left-hand side of the page
it will have the list of courses and um
all of their classes so again
everything's in one place for the
student and it's extremely friendly
very cool and then just to sort of
add that final uh answer to katherine's
question the whole classroom is
basically syncing up your existing
roster with khan academy to save you all
the pain and suffering of finding roster
students in a remote learning
environment and it makes it it makes it
so much easier and
not just for the not just for the
teacher but also for the student because
as hesitant as we are to use technology
as teachers
the students if they're not instantly
hooked into what that technology is
they're not going to want to use it and
so having those resources ready readily
available seeing what their classes are
knowing what active and past means
immediately
helps the students understand how this
resource is going to help them
very cool
so going back to this idea of doing
comparison in the social studies context
we actually had a really interesting
question from daryl
darryl says my class and i are working
on the second industrial revolution
there's some way that allows me to
attach two different readings or videos
or activities so students can compare
those two different topics side by side
for example u.s industrial revolution
compared to british industrial
revolution if i were to think about
things at once how do i do that
absolutely absolutely and so under
assignments this is where you can this
is where it's really great that you can
have more than one course um within your
khan academy classroom so you can look
at the resources in u.s history or ap us
history under um industrialization and
then look at world history under
industrialization and really pick and
choose um which assignments or which
documents within each of those courses
so they can be side by side and in
assignments you would want to make sure
that you kind of have the same date and
parameters
um so that the students know they're
connected and then within the google
classroom or
if there's another platform that you use
to give assignments um you can um be
more specific with the instructions on
how how the students are to uh connect
those uh
specific uh documents
very cool yeah definitely make multiple
assignments at once yes students on
their way
um
let's see here so another really
important question is coming in from b
richards
b says
can teachers be notified when a student
completes an assignment so that way
because we're all busy trying to
scramble and make this all work how do
we keep track of what students are doing
yes oh um
over the years khan academy has
done a really great job about asking
teachers looking at the khan academy
gradebook
and how the gradebook can be
formatted to
best parallel what their current
gradebook already looks like
so they're looking at assignments and
thank you for bringing that up and it
tells you what kind of assignment it is
um just but just as the students are
seeing these different symbols within
their khan academy the teacher is also
seeing the same symbols in their
gradebook so there's a similarity which
makes it much more user-friendly and
rememberable
whether it's a document or a video or a
multiple choice and then they've
color-coded it so green obviously you've
met um the uh threshold of
the minimum standard of percentage um
orange were kind of
we may have missed a few ideas and then
read this is an opportunity that
the student may want to revisit or
as a teacher this is where you would
really want a student
a chance to create those mini lessons of
reinforcement and review a special if
you're noticing um in your class book
for that particular assignment there may
be several students who may have may not
have understood a concept within that in
particular so
as you're looking at the assignment
scores you can clearly see who has done
it and who has not but then if you click
into a specific assignment so if uh you
can click perfect
i apologize these are math examples but
that's okay that's okay
it's the same idea so don't be scared
because it's math um
one of the things is khan academy really
does a deep dive into not just the
overall score for a student or the class
but what it was like for each individual
question and so it's no longer a
guessing game for the teacher or the
student on what they understood or what
they didn't and what needs to be
reviewed or reinforced
so if i have
you know five students in my class i
mean say five students because you know
i'm being completely unrealistic there
probably yeah i only have five students
in my world um and three of them have
missed the same question i can see that
instantly in khan academy
and
that allows me to go back to that
question
and if i'm doing um say a webinar and
i'm showing my screen in khan academy i
can actually use that question and
project it on my screen and the class
and i can actually go over that question
again
not say oh we've all missed this but hey
let's take a look at this again
what is the question truly asking okay
now let's look at the process of
elimination why why do we think this
would be this would or would not be the
answer let's talk about that let's come
to consensus
and then if i wanted to i can actually
um
use another question or an assignment
and i can have the students uh do
another multiple choice or i can you
know project what that answer is and why
that's the correct answer so again using
the date it's i love the instant data
aspect of khan academy because it is so
powerful for students um
but having the students look at a
question not just one time but multiple
times i think also helps reinforce and
then it also if you know going back to
the original question what if a student
doesn't do an assignment
if you notice the student doesn't do the
assignment but it also happens to be
a question where an area where a lot of
students need extra support
that can then bring the student back
into the conversation not have them feel
completely left out or i didn't do the
assignment therefore i can't participate
so finding ways to use the data as a way
to
get that interaction with students and
reinforcement
i love that it really comes back to what
you said at the very beginning
khan academy is not replacing the
teacher it's a tool to completely
complement the teacher's strengths and
expertise and you apply it judiciously
um one last question this is a really
important one from pete
pete says you know even in this world of
trying to get everyone online make
remote learning work overnight basically
right i still need to keep in mind
differentiated education serving every
student where they are
how can we do that in this new digital
world using a tool like con
um i'm going to go back to khan academy
and their relationship with the college
board and sat
where
the practice is based specifically on
the individual student score report so
that becomes differentiated right there
so if i'm a teacher and i'm having my
students and and by the way every
subject is an sat subject it's not just
strictly a
english or a math it is every subject is
sat because every subject has reading
every subject has analysis so you can
use it in many different ways
going on that
i can have a student i can have my
students
go to a specific practice and it's
already set up for where they are
in um
their uh skill level within the sat
and so it's not leaving anybody behind
it's not assuming that everybody knows
everything or everybody is at the same
level because that's unrealistic in any
classroom
um
when i'm looking at the lessons
one of the things that i can do is i can
look at the lessons and go okay
i'm gonna you know have the students
maybe do a little bit of a practice
question beforehand
and then i can ha then i can look at the
results and then i can differentiate a
lesson from there whether it's
reinforcement with a video whether it's
reinforcement with a document because
we've done some multiple choice and
here's a document
that complements it or i can um look at
some of the key questions
that may have been a little bit more
difficult and then i can break it down a
little bit more so i am differentiating
um for students who may have difficulty
understanding what a question is asking
or having difficulty with a concept
within the question so i've
so for so many times i've taken
a multiple choice question and i've
projected it on my screen um in my
classroom
or my whiteboard actually because it's a
little bit more interactive and i will
yeah i will i will literally project it
onto
my whiteboard and i'll we'll start
writing all over it
and i will have the students working in
groups and one group will come up and
they'll do that so but in you know
because we have this now uh distance
learning um having the students do that
in their own way and there's some
platforms that do allow that
um but it's
if we're on a webcam it's a piece of
paper and a pen or pencil
is that that can be our technology on
how to uh differentiate and one of the
things that a teacher can do is by the
results that students uh give whether
it's on the piece of paper or the
multiple choice or the document the
teacher can start differentiating a
little bit from there and scaffold
some of the skills that they see need a
little bit more reinforcement uh
throughout that lesson
very cool and so just to sort of
illustrate that point here if you
realize that someone is weak in a
certain core area especially with the ap
exam approaching you can always assign
that not to the entire class
particularly specifically
exactly
um okay i know we're a little bit over
time so i do want to end with one final
question which is just you know folks
didn't get their questions answered
today or your amazing expertise has
opened up new questions they didn't
realize they had before where would you
recommend they go for support based on
your experience with khan academy
um one of the things that i found is
looking at that resource page
because it gives ideas not just how to
set the classroom but different ideas on
how to
look at khan academy for uh
differentiation for
whole class practice for
looking at remediation and so forth that
resource page is
it's really phenomenal because it does
empower the teacher which
in turn empowers students and
the big thing with khan academy is
if you want to jump right into it great
start small you don't have to you don't
have to do everything on cad academy at
the same time because that would be
overwhelming for you and the students
pick one thing
start with one thing get comfortable
with that and then add one more thing
maybe try one thing a week
this week we're going to try multiple
choice let's see how that goes okay so
now we've done our multiple choice okay
how can we do some differentiation with
that okay next week let's take a look at
some documents next week let's take a
look at how we can
incorporate a video and start maybe a
socratic seminar uh based on that
particular document start small get
comfortable and build up from there and
you're gonna find that the more you get
comfortable with it the more you get
excited about how to bring in more
aspects of khan academy that you hadn't
even thought of before
very cool it's so parallel to how our
students learn right they have to have
that solid foundation
before they can extend it and do even
more incredible applications and the
same is true for us as educators
absolutely
cool well erin on behalf of the entire
audience i want to thank you so much for
sharing your expertise today um i think
you've given us so many tools and
resources during a very tough time and
for that we really appreciate all your
generosity thank you so much for having
me i really appreciate it and um thank
you all for being uh being willing to
take on khan academy because it is it is
really exciting and i was fortunate to
wear
um i've seen khan academy progress
over the years to help students but also
teachers and khan academy continues to
do that all the time they're bringing
out new curriculum they're bringing out
new resources for teachers and students
and
um it's a really it's a really exciting
time to see what's going to happen next
with khan academy
very cool well thanks everyone for
joining us investing in the session
today thank you again aaron wish you all
a good evening a good night have a good
evening
you